i am mad and not like grab a sculpting
hammer and bash my head in with it mad
more like a why did i watch six hours of
an otherwise phenomenal show to get this
[Music]
okay okay i know i'm being a bit
hyperbolic but i think making this video
will be a bit cathartic for me and
hopefully you in understanding why i
dislike this ending so much
and i think part of why i didn't like it
had to do with how much better it could
have been
the pieces had been perfectly laid out
by creator david e kelly yet they
weren't utilized making many of the
setups well
feel like they served no purpose so in
this video i'm gonna do two things first
start off with why i thought the ending
was bad using examples from the show
and secondly how i would have ended it
including who i thought the killer
should have been
and how the show inadvertently set it up
to be an amazing payoff that
well never did pay off if you just want
to get to the alternate ending i'll
leave a timestamp in the description but
before we begin
make sure to like and subscribe and if
you ended up liking it be sure to check
out my other how it should have ended
videos
now i know the first thing a lot of you
will be saying is think story the show
is based off a book you can't just
change the ending well i disagree for
two reasons one if the book has a bad
ending then maybe don't adapt it in the
first place and second
adaptations are simply that they adapt
screen rant has a great article on 15
movie adaptations completely different
from their books which i'll leave a link
to in the description
you can change things there's no law
saying you have to be a hundred percent
faithful to the source material and at
the end of the day
i want whatever is gonna give me the
best story so in the actual ending
jonathan ends up kidnapping his son
after he feels he'll lose his murder
trial whereupon he contemplates suicide
culminating in a dramatic will he won't
he as he hovers over the edge of a
bridge
and the first thing i'll say right off
the bat here is that this was way too
rushed this all happens in the last 10
minutes of a six
hour mini series which for the most part
has been a great slow burn
we basically go from measured courthouse
drama to
wild chase scene with jon's car narrowly
missing a huge truck in a matter of
minutes
tonally it just seems out of place it
also seems out of place for jonathan's
character
him turning completely unhinged would
have been easier to understand
if the show gave us more moments that
hinted at this dr
jackal and mr hyde complex i mean we do
get moments like him in the prison where
he bites this dude's finger
but that's kind of at least warranted in
that situation
i was also completely underwhelmed with
the reveal of him being the killer i
felt that these six episodes were
building up to a
massive twist and i was left deflated
dare i say empty
finding out it was him the whole time we
also don't really get
any sort of catharsis to take this all
in as grace and henry fly off in a
private helicopter at the end there's no
real moment to decompress
and how did the police just let grace
run past them to a man who's on the edge
of a bridge
and who they themselves have deemed
armed and dangerous it just felt
far-fetched in a show that otherwise had
been relatively grounded
at the end of the day i just found the
man was crazy the whole time ending to
be too easy predictable
and emotionally empty so what i want to
do is offer an
alternative one that gets rid of the
whole chase scene ending altogether
and centers around a different killer
and if you've been paying close
attention to the show
it has already given us tons of clues
pointing at this person who would also
have motivation to kill elena
i'm referring to grace's friend sylvia
steinitz as soon as elena's murder is
discovered in episode 1
it's sylvia who is all over it she seems
to be the first to know everything
calling grace to tell her what she knows
and already offering someone else as the
prime suspect
evidently they were having problems it's
always the [ __ ] husband she also
plays the role of the comforting best
friend who's always by her
side even in the courtroom but those
points aren't the strongest
let's get into the real meat and
potatoes of it all in episode 2 we
learned that john hired sylvia several
months ago
when he was going through his
disciplinary meetings at the hospital
he hired me a few months ago this
establishes a connection between the two
that was hidden from grace
something sylvia said she had to keep
secret due to attorney-client privilege
so already there's something a little
shady going on here we also know from
episode 4 that jon had one other affair
that's quickly brought up and never
talked about again
were there any others other women you've
been involved with during the course of
your marriage
there was one what if this other woman
was sylvia the two would have known each
other for years
through grace plus they had secret
meetings regarding his case at the
hospital
meetings which were kept from grace once
sylvia saw john's love for elena the new
girl
she would be the one to become obsessed
following john around as his affair with
elena deepened
ultimately murdering her in a fit of
rage after she'd watched jon leave her
artist studio
realizing that she's gone way too far
she'd obviously want to cover it up
making
jon the prime suspect if you do
learn where jonathan is
tell the police that murder weapon the
sculpting hammer henry finds at the
beach house could have easily been
placed there by sylvia who would know a
how to get there and b that grace would
be staying there
sylvia is also a lawyer so she'd know
better than most on how to go about
covering her tracks and making the right
moves
moves which would further implicate jon
in the murder she also has a lot to lose
her
own family and going to jail for the
rest of her life so the best course of
action for her is to pin this on jon
another thread which had no significance
to the actual ending but could be woven
into this new
ending is silvia's relationship with
prosecuting attorney
katherine stamper they used to intern
together for a bit when they first
started off as lawyers but this
connection never really pays off in the
show she waves to her when entering the
court and there's another meaningless
scene with them in the washroom but if
sylvia actually killed elena
catherine would be a powerful ally to
have when you're the actual murderer so
i guess this all comes down to how
sylvia would be caught and i think the
best way to do this would be through
haley fitzgerald
bringing sylvia to the stand haley has
said multiple times throughout the
season
that she'll be able to find anything out
i will find
out hell she was able to hack into all
the jurors facebooks and manipulate the
advertisements they were fed what if she
secretly knew something about sylvia
couldn't 100 prove it but had to use her
wits to get a confession out of her
while on the stand we've already seen
how haley can amp
up the pressure and elicit huge
reactions from those she questions
like what happened to fernando i'd
equate this scene to that famous one in
a few good men where tom cruise's
character slowly applies pressure until
jack nicholson snaps you can't handle
the truth
this could also be juxtaposed with
flashbacks of sylvia committing the
murder
kind of like how we saw jon commit it in
the real version it would also be a big
reveal for grace
john and everyone else in the courtroom
leading me to believe it would be a more
satisfying and rewarding ending than the
haphazard chase scene we got there's
even room to see what would happen to
these characters after the trial and
allow us to decompress
all in all this is just what i came up
with in a little bit of time so there
are probably lots of better options and
ways to go about ending the show i even
thought about covering the grandfather
as the potential killer as there are
almost
just as many hidden clues that point to
him as well but i want to hear what you
thought of the ending am i completely
wrong here or would you have liked to
have seen something different
make sure to leave a comment below
thanks for watching everyone make sure
to like subscribe and share and for more
bad takes you can always follow me on
twitter and instagram
at thingstoryt until next time remember
daddy loves you very much
you